[Musica]
E lui disse
Eccomi solo
che cosa sono
un servo una cartone
ma non è mostruoso
che quest'uomo qui
fingendo una passione anzi sognandola
entri a tal punto in ciò che immaginario
da venir meno e diventare un altro la
voce rotta il viso sfatto gli occhi
pieni di lacrime e tutte le sue azioni i
suoi gesti tutto studiato
per dar vita e forma
a un'immagine
E tutto questo per niente
Ma chi è ecuba per lui o lui per lei per
piangerla quel modo
Buon pomeriggio ancora
qualcuno di voi l'avrà sicuramente
riconosciuto Questo è uno è l'inizio di
uno dei più grandi meravigliosi
monologhi dalla drammaturgia mondiale di
tutti i tempi Amleto William Shakespeare
secondo atto una compagnia di attori
girovaghi giunge alla corte di Danimarca
Amleto chiede al primo attore di
recitare un frammento dell'assassinio
Del Vecchio re di Priamo ad opera
di Pirro e il conseguente feroce
doloroso
disperato girovagare della regina sua
moglie La vecchia ecuba
[Musica]
l'attore È
coinvolgente
Amleto è sconvolto quando gli attori
vanno via dice Ma come è possibile
Come fa un attore
a diventare la sua immaginazione
Ed è proprio attraverso questo
straordinario processo di scomposizione
e composizione da stamattina abbiamo
sentito grande poesia intorno a questa a
questa cosa a questo meccanismo che
permette a Questo piccolo grande
miracolo diventare la propria
immaginazione di accadere
non è un abbiamo capito Non è un
processo così astratto come sembra
è estremamente concreto E anche
quotidiano la masticazione del cibo
lo scomponiamo gli facciamo fare il
viaggio all'interno di noi perde la sua
forma originaria si trasforma in energia
finalmente ci nutre Oppure non lo so i
tarocchi perché ci crede Non ci crede
uguale si mescolano Si rimescolano si
mescolano si rimescono e alla fine si
ricompongono in una stesa si dice così
che offre un piccolo oracolo al
consultante e ascoltando questa soffiata
dal destino mi piace chiamarla così il
consultante cambia
muta si trasforma Ma perché si trasforma
perché noi reagiamo continuamente al
mondo fuori di noi e se imparassimo ad
essere sempre più presenti a questo
nostro reagire probabilmente saremo
Ammirati da questo processo noi ci
scomponiamo e ricomponiamo costantemente
e ogni nostra reazione al mondo di fuori
Invia un piccolo segnale unico
attraverso il sistema nervoso che è un
grande mediatore del nostro dentro e del
nostro fuori un piccolo unico segnale
all'interno delle nostre cellule ai geni
e i geni
cosa fanno producono dei mattoncini che
ci costruiscono che costruiscono questa
meravigliosa macchina che ci fa
attraversare la vita e il mondo sono le
proteine ora però piccolo Gap c'è Le
proteine sono 29 i geni sono
23.688 mentre le proteine sono 140.000
come è possibile che il numero delle
proteine sia straordinariamente
superiore a quello dei geni che le
producono e qui c'è poesia altissima
ogni igiene ha la possibilità di
esprimersi attraverso migliaia di
varianti e ogni variante si accende o si
spegne come le lucine di Natale a
seconda del segnale che Noi inviamo
dall'esterno quindi stiamo attenti
come reagiamo perché quello ci
costruisce
il nostro sistema quindi è operosissimo
accensioni spegnimenti tutto si scioglie
tutto si riunisce gli alchemisti
dicevano dicono anche ancora solve e
coagula la grande opera alchemica non è
altro che un processo spirituale la
trasformazione del piombo della materia
interiore parliamo sempre delle terre di
dentro della materia interiore inerte
buia incosciente
nell'oro della consapevolezza la pietra
filosofale non è Un gingillo
fosforescente Ma è un distillato
interiore è il frutto di una
disgregazione ancora puterefazione
nigredo e di una ricomposizione in
purezza rubedo
sempre per familiarizzare col processo
c'è una cosa che mi ha sempre
affascinato il kingsong In Giappone è un
artigianato raffinatissimo che
aggiusta gli oggetti rotti crepati con
la lacca è con loro però è anche un
processo
di
rinarrazione di un evento come l'abbiamo
percepito E come si fa
Come si fa a rinarrare un evento che
abbiamo già vissuto
si permette dentro
un'accettazione nuova accettazione non è
rassegnazione accettazione vuol dire
guardare un oggetto un evento da tutte
le angolazioni e ci si posiziona
differentemente
questo permette alla nostra anima di
muoversi in un altro modo di non cadere
nei soliti meccanismi e solchi di sempre
non sempre rassegnazione non sempre
vittimismo non sempre Dio mio non ce la
farò mai No una nuova strada rinarrare
vuol dire rinascere
rinarrare può anche operare una
guarigione dare un nuovo senso a una
malattia a un malessere vuol dire anche
imprimerli un nuovo senso di marcia e il
senso non è solo il significato
Ma può anche essere appunto la direzione
Magari il significato di una malattia
non è nella causa sarà nel fine un
milione di anni fa non tanti io e la mia
famiglia Ci siamo prodotti in una
favolosa caduta da una scala mobile devo
dire che è stato piuttosto traumatico
perché vedere i miei genitori che
volavano sopra la mia testa insomma non
è stato facile Questo soprattutto
all'inizio però miracolosamente
sono atterrati indenni non il mio
ginocchio
Io sono rimasta immobile a casa per 10
giorni in quei dieci giorni mi sono
capitati tra le mani un paio di volumi
che io non avrei mai mai letto mai
quei libri cambiarono la mia visione del
mondo
cambiarono il mio sguardo sulle cose
Grazie a questo
la mia memoria
ha impresso questo accadimento non in
maniera traumatica la nota traumatica
non c'è più io Ho trattenuto la bellezza
perché quel cadere all'indietro mi ha
permesso di riposizionarmi
interiormente insieme ai miei antenati
Boh magari direte Questa è una pazza Può
essere Però questa immagine
nell'anima c'è e mi costituisce c'è un
grande regista Quentin Tarantino lui è
abilissimo nel rinarrare un passato nel
dare al passato una nuova possibilità e
quindi guarirlo
in Bastardi senza gloria lui fa morire
Hitler che di noi non la desiderato lo
fa morire in un incendio in un cinema
Guarda caso proprio all'indomani
dellobrobrio che noi tutti conosciamo
quindi non si è mai verificato quello
che sappiamo oppure in Django lui regala
dona a un popolo di
gli schiavi un eroe che gli riscatta
Django mai accaduto in quella storia in
quella di Tarantino Sì E cosa più
commovente
lui permette a Sharon Tate di continuare
a vivere di continuare a vivere e di far
nascere la sua creatura commovente E
adesso siamo qui a quel quesito Quella
risposta una delle possibili risposte al
quesito di Amleto Come fa un attore a
diventare la sua immaginazione
Questo è il mestiere che mi sono scelta
e l'avventura di me in questa vita
l'arte drammatica intrisa di un processo
di scomposizione E ricomposizione noi
siamo dei cantastorie scegliamo un testo
e lo scomponiamo lo analizziamo per
comprenderlo per prenderlo con noi per
abbracciarlo con ogni Fibra del nostro
essere e alla fine di quel bagno di
analisi noi lo mettiamo in scena
cosa accade in quel bagno di analisi a
ogni elemento che lo costituisce Noi
diamo una nuova connessione perché nuova
perché sono io Pia con la mia storia
personale che passo Ai raggi x quel
testo tu lo fai in un altro modo tu in
un altro modo il testo è lo stesso Lo
scritto è lo stesso ma il silenzio gli
spazi che ci sono tra quelle lettere
possono essere abitati da miriade di
storie un attore può interpretare un
personaggio
un altro attore in un altro modo stesso
personaggio uno stesso attore può
interpretare lo stesso personaggio in
modi diametralmente opposti nell'arco
della propria vita perché perché la vita
lo ha cambiato lo ha rimescolato come
succedeva con i tarocchi
Ora noi raccontiamo storie e le storie
Lo sappiamo tutti ci cambiano la vita i
libri film Wherever Ma come si fa le
storie sono catartiche ci purificano da
quei detriti che ci ostruiscono lo
sguardo ci permettono di incamminarci su
nuove strade come
operando una trasformazione come quando
noi guardiamo qualcuno su uno schermo o
in scena a cui accade qualcosa
quel qualcosa gli fa intraprendere un
viaggio quel viaggio lo facciamo anche
noi spettatori insieme a lui e ci
Trasformiamo insieme a lui
trasformarsi
trasformare vuol dire andare oltre la
forma abituale quindi c'è una forma di
prima è una forma che emerge dopo ma
dopo che dopo questo benedetto viaggio
cioè il viaggio dell'attore il viaggio
del personaggio Il viaggio dello
spettatore questi viaggi ci fanno
traversare dei mondi i mondi li
Attraversiamo noi il viaggio di un
attore è quello di scomporre analizzare
cercare tutte le dinamiche del
personaggio mettere in dubbio provare
altre strade a prendere il Largo magari
navigare senza l'aiuto degli Astri e
quindi magari naufragare e questo è
terrificante Perché ogni volta o durante
le prove o durante un set No no basta
Allora non ce la faccio Son bloccato Non
capisco niente basta non cagna basta
smetto non ce la fa terribile Sono delle
listerie feroci poi alla fine
si approda una terra che magari è la
stessa che abbiamo lasciato
quando siamo saltati Ma sarà sicuramente
diversa perché noi abbiamo fatto questo
viaggio
è semplice E anche banale dirlo lo
sappiamo tutti il viaggio della vita ci
cambia la vita ci scrive addosso noi
riportiamo segni visibili o invisibili
quotidianamente ci scomponiamo durante
il giorno ci ricomponiamo nel sonno o
anche viceversa
come noi reagiamo al mondo come noi ci
disintegriamo contro il mondo e come ci
ricomponiamo questo lo facciamo noi
umani Noi attori vi facciamo vedere come
e studiamo per questo e lo dice Amleto
ogni parola ogni gesto tutto studiato
per dar vita e forma a un'immagine
E l'immagine è un atto dell'anima senza
anima non produciamo niente di
interessante l'anima ha si dialoga con
l'anima con la parte sommersa dell'anima
attraverso le immagini sono grandi atti
di immaginazione
il mio maestro strehler diceva fate atti
di meraviglie grande atto di
immaginazione è il rito Noi abbiamo
bisogno di riti il rito il teatro per
esempio cambia chi lo compie da una
forma diversa a una sostanza a un
oggetto
da una sostanza diversa Ha un evento
un filo a teatro non è un filo e basta
un filo e una porta
dei bastoni di legno appoggiati a una
parete al passaggio di un uomo possono
diventare un plotone di esecuzione una
serie di secchi di latta con dell'acqua
dentro possono essere un lago e se io
alla Clemente secchio dopo secchio
decido di costruire intorno alla persona
che amo un cerchio
di secchi li sto forse
comunicando il mio amore Il lago del mio
cuore un sacco di tempo fa
nel Pleistocene più o meno a Parigi
ho visto un Amleto meraviglioso e le
ultime battute di Amleto sono prima di
morire tra le braccia di Orazio sono il
resto e silenzio Questo attore fece una
scelta differente Appunto nel silenzio e
lui si alzò si girò spalle al pubblico
si avviò lentamente verso il fondo del
palcoscenico
rallentò si fermò
inclinò la testa
quelli inclinare il capo indicava che
era venuto il trapasso
era morto
e io ero commossa il mio fidanzato
vicino si chiama Che cagata ma va ti
pare che uno muore così ma che vuol dire
io ero io c'avevo creduto veramente è
morto così è morto in piedi col testo
con la testa inclinata ci avevo creduto
come ci credono i bambini quando giocano
i bambini quando giocano che fanno
ridisegnano le loro identità
ricreano le loro credenze diventano
maghi diventano impostori diventano
laghi montagne mostri marini Wherever
loro ci credono hanno la Fede che gli
sostiene la Fede è un elemento
trasformatore gigantesco come l'amore
come la volontà come il fuoco
loro ci credono per questo sono
credibili così facciamo noi attori noi
ci crediamo noi ci identifichiamo in
un'immagine piuttosto che un'altra noi
giustapponiamo le ferite della nostra
anima a quelle del personaggio
sostituiamo elementi vissuti o
Immaginati a quelli del personaggio noi
e i personaggi ci incontriamo in un
interregno
misterioso e creiamo dei piccoli mondi E
soprattutto non li giudichiamo mai non
ci sono personaggi cattivi buoni perché
a ognuno diamo le ragioni di ogni azione
perché giudicando Puntando il dito non
ci separiamo e invece noi danziamo con
il nostro personaggio perché cadiamo con
lui ci rialziamo con lui danziamo
E questa danza ci fa trasformare
e trasformandoci
Trasformiamo anche voi che ci ascoltate
e che mai vide che orrore
la regina imbacuccata
correre scalza
minacciando i roghi
c'è chi gli occhi da piangere
uno straccio in testa dove era sempre
stato Il diadema e intorno al nudo
scheletro che un tempo fu fertile
una coperta
afferrata nella fuga
che mai La vide avrebbe denunciato di
tradimento e frode la fortuna
ma se gli dai l'avessero ascoltata
se gli dai l'avessero sentita
quando vide che Pirro Prima stava per
gioco nelle carni del marito
se l'avessero sentita
lanciare un muro
altissimo
quel grido
per poco che sappiamo noi umani
commuovere gli dei
avrebbe dato latte di pianto
anche ai lontani e ardenti sguardi degli
altri
quel grido
avrebbe emozionato il cielo
impariamo
a rimarrrare i nostri giorni
non facciamolo fare solo agli artisti
propriamente detti facciamo dell'arte
nella nostra vita così potremmo anche
ricomporci
in un enorme inchino di gratitudine
a questa forza stupefacente che è
l'amore
[Musica]
che muove il Sole e l'altre stelle come
disse Voi sapete che
[Applauso]